Hello everyone, my name is Erin, from IBM.
I'm here with you today to discuss: what is
a power systems virtual server?
So, let's talk really quick about why clients, or users, in fact,
might want to try out, or stay with, a power systems virtual server.
So, maybe they've been on-premises for a long time.
Maybe they want to test out capabilities with a virtual server.
We'll go through what those capabilities are.
Historically, we find that a lot of people
like power systems because of
scalability, reliability, the performance for the mission-critical workloads that it affords,
as well as just that reliability. So  - and security, sorry.
OK, so let's go into: what is a power systems virtual server?
Well, first of all, you have your server on-premises.
This is where power systems live in the data centers
and they are connected to storage.
Important to note here: both of these are
going to be enterprise grade,
and the storage is actually going to be run on all solid-state drives.
Now, what makes the virtual server portion
of this?
You have your operating systems that come in.
Operating systems.
So, the types of operating systems that you have for Power VS:
AIX, IBMi, ... Linux comes to the party to hang out.
So, these are your operating systems. IBM is going to manage up to the operating system
and then the user, or the client after, can manage everything beyond that.
So, you have the availability to do things like test,
we'll go into some of the use cases in a bit there.
What I also really like the, one of the features about this:
the minimum requirement for a core on one of these operating systems is a quarter of a core.
That's very small.
So, you don't have to get the whole server,
you can get a portion of that,
and you can scale as you desire with that.
OK, so 0.25 of a core. They can be shared or dedicated.
They can be capped or uncapped.
So, we'll allude to that later in the use cases, but a lot of people love
the bursting capability that that allows.
Now let's go into ...
I'll leave a little bit of room at the top here because,
on top of your operating systems, you can run applications. Which is really cool.
So, let's go by AIX first.
You have your SAP HANA, Oracle and Epic.
Those are applications that you can run on top of your AIX operating system.
Let's go next with IBMi.
So, these are a little bit different. They're going to be specific by tiers, I like to call them.
So, you have your major - and those are going to be SAP, Oracle, and Infor.
So, your major tiers.
You have your industry tiers, which is going to be Fiserv, and Jack Henry, for example.
And then you have your tools-based tier.  So, that's going to be like help systems or Precisely.
And now, let's go on over to ... let's use some pink for this one ... Mr. Linux.
SAP HANA is what you can run, application-wise for Linux.
So, we have our server connected to our storage.
We have our operating systems, and we have the applications that we can run with as little as a quarter of a core.
Finally, let's go over and talk about some use cases.
There are quite a few, but there are 3
that I find that people really like.
So, the first one, let's talk about: HA/DR - High
Availability Disaster Recovery.
So, Power VS has 13 data centers globally,
and then the availability to fail over disaster recovery-wise if there's a storm,
if there's a, you know, natural disaster, to have another data center to connect to
in the event of a disaster or just, you know, to have protection of your data.
HA/DR is probably one of the top use cases that we see for Power VS.
Another one I mentioned: maybe you want to test out the availability of a virtual server.
What is it? What does it afford opportunity-wise?
What's the future going to look like for that?
A lot of people like the DevTest capability.
You can, again with as little of quarter of a core, develop and test
on these virtual servers with that connection into the server in the IBM data centers.
So, DevTest provides a lot of people with the flexibility that they're looking for
especially if you're a power on-prem customer.
And then, the last one I mentioned before, the availability to burst.
So, remember, with these cores, they can be shared or dedicated, capped or uncapped,
and they have the availability to "burst"
- as in going up and down, based on what you use.
So, you can actually burst beyond the capacity of what you have
if you need it, which is really nice.
So, Power VS is metered and billed by the hour, based on what you use.
So, that bursting capability is really of interest
to a lot of users.
So, in a nutshell, we have our "what is a power systems virtual server" here.
Thank you for being here with us today.
If you have questions, please drop us a line below.
If you want to see more videos like this in
the future, please like and subscribe.